γιαλις εξιάθλητς τον εποίον ι τρεις ήταν που έλαβαν και μέρως λιπαούσανγόνες του ρίο τοτεμιλαντραϊκόβις
λεωντιά καλένου καιο αποστόοσο παρέλλης απόστο ο εντάξι ήταν ίδι ήταν είχεν ίδη παρολιμδιακούς τα
αλλάδιο τα παιδιά όχι και κάτι που έχει κιπικειο ίδιος ομήλα τότε συ είανε τον
ήξερε κανένας και μέσα π αυτό το πρόγραμμα κάπου έτσι των αναγνωρίσ ναναγνωρίσαμε την προπτυγ
κι αυτό είναι το πιο δύσκολον όταν προσπάσει να στηριξει ζητικάναρα ταλέντα να αναγνωρίσεις πία
από αυτούς ι αυτές μπορούν να πάρουν την πρόκληση μπορούν να ου α υού ψηλά
σίγουρα δεν μπορείς να τους αναγνωρήσεις όλους θα κάνουε θα γίνουν λάθει αλλά είναι σημαντικών
να προσπαθείς να βοηθήσεις και επιδ όπως ίπαπρι στα παποσια του ήμουν δηλαδή να είσισε
μια ιο είναι αρηνηλγία να μην υπάρχει ι στηριξη που χρειάζεσαι και να προσπαθείς να
διεκρική ις ολπακή πρόκριση είναι πάραπολή σιμαντικό να έρθει αυτό το ετα εικονομικό πους να
μπορείς να πασε ένα γόναμπερισότερο να μπορες να αγορασι η λιγάαναμπορίς να εντάξεις κάποιον μέσα
στην ομάδα σο και αυτό ξεκίνησε πρώτα με το τόκιο του ορστόκιο και όπως είπε
στων μάσαμε ενέργεια θλητικής ευθύνης και το τόκιοστηρίκτηκαν πέντεαθλτες τρεις εκτονοποίον πήγανολυμπιακούς τρεις κοπέλλες ι
άντρι χριστοφόρου η μαριλά μακρί και να δασερά παάντρει στην ποδιασίαν η απόμενες δίσυνηστιοπλοία και
οι δύο άντρες ο όμήρος οδάγκαστηγκολύμβισηκαιο πάρι οπατσαβαλι στο αγκοντισμό που δεν καταφέρα να πάρουν
ηυπρόκρηση τοτε τα χρήματα τα μαζεύαμε είχαμε προϊόντα καπελακι και δο πλουσζά καταποία πουλούσαμενστομέσω διαδικτίου
ιστων αυτικών λεμεο πικελιγξοπτελιακόμτ όλα τα καθαράεισότα πήγε στηστηριξη των αθλητών και συνεχίστηκε ναυτό με
το τόρ πάρεις το ίκο σικοστρία ήταν